what I don't understand is when people
get tattoos in other languages that they
don't understand that's that's weird to
me people getting tattoos in Arabic and
can't read them first tattoo when I was
16 it's a tattoo of black panther with
the words free Huey Huey P Newton found
that a black panther party my parents
didn't know I had this tattoo blew my
cover one day because it started raining
in the neighborhood then I came to crib
soapy and I just took my shirt off my
mom's like on a South Side of Chicago
where I grew up five blocks from Obama's
house and five blocks from project
buildings gave me a lens on just
inequality in the world I've always
tried to get tattoos with intent up to
something on my skin and on my body
because it really represented something
important to me I've actually had a
couple near-death experiences I was
shocked by 15,000 volts of electricity
when I was 17 years old
there was a gorgeous Spanish foreign
exchange student
when I was bringing her downtown to go
to LA Palooza
she had tickets I didn't try to sneak in
I thought I could climb off this bridge
that carried the power for the metro
trains kind of my floor wrong touch the
transformer with 15,000 volts of
electricity a lot of my elbow now fell
30 feet because I was on a bridge when I
realized you know my arm wasn't moving
and it was like smoking just a gas
and this was all white Metro Police game
I could have just said I fell off the
bridge but I was like I was trying to
sneak in but I got electrocuted can you
take me to the hospital it was like [ __ ]
you make it threw me in the back of car
you know so I got arrested too that's
one my side by a really dope artist
named Shawn from Texas and the words are
disrupt it has a line drawing a car
crash with a deep capitated passenger
and the words I'm fine don't call the
cops underneath it really made me think
about when I fell off the bridge you
know but I never told him that story I
didn't really have any conversation and
he made something that you know really
related to my experience resistance
whatever the thing you get in like fifth
grade but my big brother somebody that
really opened the door for me and gave
me a vote of confidence when I was young
where I was a graffiti writer I started
off writing graffiti before I have a
started rapping his name was dead he was
killed and gun violence and I got this
tattoo to commemorate him
most of my ties I get in random places
in America just while I'm moving around
recording on tour slave this is
something that Prince wrote on his face
he was in battles with his record label
at some base level we're all slaves to
something whether it's slaves to our
iPhones or yahoo and google there are
very few of us living a free life you
know sometimes I go I Drive by a
homeless man and wonder who's more free
you know I don't I don't have a specific
style of tattoos that I go for I usually
design all my tattoos in Photoshop
I've Photoshop like the tattoos or
photos of me save money yeah it was
always meant to be kind of an antithesis
to your run-of-the-mill rap materialism
I've never been into retouching tattoos
anything like that I don't understand
now on to the point I got this so I can
live with it it can live with me and
it's gonna take on its own life it's
gonna fade it's gonna crack stretch
change I think that's dope mr.
Rockefeller logo growing up it was
Rockefeller to me that was everything as
I started to make my own music that was
always a huge influence in hopes of
being up there with the greatest me and
my boy Joe Perth we got these tattoos
together we did a song called seven
seven three seven seven three that's my
phone number
I've had the same phone number since
seventh grade I'm never changing never
switching up and keep it real you know
keep it authentic what a biggie survey
said I called a [ __ ] saying on the same
hood it's all good
it's a ding crest symbol my family is
from West Africa from Ghana it shows two
lizards with two heads but the same body
and it kind of like symbolizes universal
consciousness you forget how
interconnected we all are as human
beings and that we all do and have it
the same space and we have to breathe
the same air we have to drink the same
water right now we're in a time when
people are manipulating us to feel more
separated than to feel connected when in
actuality there's a lot more unifying us
than there is dividing us